one of the most profound things
I ever heard yeah
with no meat on the bone the late great
Charlie Murphy he said [__] run the
world so the world is run by [__]
meaning most of those guys that are
making us all you know miserable and all
of that couldn't fight their way out of
a [__] wet paper bag they never had
to
but they have all this money and power
so they got all these people to fight
their fights for them and then Charlie
Murphy you know is looking at himself or
like he could have [__] any of them up
but
he doesn't have their juice so then a
guy like him a [__] who he was a
[__] Warrior man I saw him one time
with the [__] Tempe Improv get into
it with this guy where they were just
talking about martial arts and whose
style was better and child was just
going like I'm telling you man my Styles
I I I've fought against guys like you
you're not you're not going to get me
the kid was like all right let's go
and they would just [__] twisting
each other and Travis looking over me
smiling just handling the dude
and like Charlie at that point was you
know late 40s and this kid was like in
his 20s he was still you know full of
piss and vinegar and he had no problem
with them
what's up that's awesome yeah man I uh
that's awesome I've lost a lot of
friends with that that you know and all
the friends that I think of that guy I
think about him in this stuff that he
said a lot
a lot I really miss that guy man he had
a smile man he had a [__] stories he
had you know those true those Charlie
Murphy True Hollywood stories
too he had me cry and laughing
I can't say the names it's his story I
wasn't there but he was talking about
how he was at a party one time and there
was a
current boxing champion there
of some weight class
and he was drunk
and he was trying he was telling
everybody there that he could throw four
punches in under a second this close to
your rib cage and he wouldn't hit you
and he kept hitting guys
because he was drunk and they'd be like
oh they [__] go down and then he
would go you moved you moved right and
they weren't moving they were just
hammered so now it was just I was going
like why were people doing that and he
was going like I don't know the way he
told the story
it was just basically a bunch of goofy
white guys
who wanted to [__] get in go with
this guy so they were literally to a
[__] boxing champion we're going like
this and he put his head in there okay
in the last one [__] crack that ribs
and these guys were folding
oh and then he would just be like oh you
moved man you and he couldn't tell if he
was [__] with them or whatever but he
said
he was in the kitchen because he didn't
he goes like he goes I don't be near
that [__] he was drunk he's
crazy because that's the champ I don't
want to be near him so Charlie had like
a respect for him but he also saw the
show and the story so he was like
standing in the doorway peeking and
watching these white guys in their
[__] you know button-down shirts like
me getting folded over
oh man that's great yo he had that one
he had an O.J story dude he had some
[__] stories of like
it was such a specific era
the people when he would tell those
stories of who was there
dude he would tell stories would be like
you know it was like me Eddie
Eddie the the uh the second lead on
Knight Rider and [__] the guy from
Hardcastle McCormick it was just like I
was like what you guys oh yeah
ha
that's great it would just be this [__]
that they were doing
and there was like no cell phone cameras
or anything
and and it was such a small puddle too
dude as far as who was famous so if you
got there dude the [__] money
was was nuts you know what's amazing
about a guy like uh
Charlie Murphy rest his soul
there are certain people you feel their
presence like I remember I ran into that
guy at stand-up New York and he was on
stage doing a joke I said something to
him after just a big smile and just like
what you felt the dude like certain
people you [__] feel when they're
there man Charlie had that where it was
like
he came in the room you've sensed he was
in the room he had that [__] laugh
and then also he was like he was a fun
guy
and he was a [__] like guys guy and
he was he was a warrior too and like you
know it's just one of those you can just
feel like I'm not [__] with that guy
I wish I was like that guy I wish I
could handle somebody the way that I
mean he was like a [__]
um
he was hilarious dude and then he was
also like really like inquisitive
like really
you know like how so well you know if he
met somebody
you know you just like he would he would
get into [__] that he wouldn't think he
would get into you know what I mean
which I think is the artist's brain
where a lot of people it's kind of like
hey I'm from here this is how you do
things and you kind of stay in that
world and that's how you kind of become
like a character in a way he would he
would like know about [__] or be in the
[__] that you never thought
he would uh
he would be into and then the other [__]
that you'd think you'd be into he knew
all the way down to like bedrock
like this like when he talked about
martial arts and he talked about guys
too man he could like
he could do 20 minutes on those martial
arts magazines because he used to read
him when he was a kid and he used to
always laughing at the the guy getting
his ass kicked on the cover he read me
cracking up about that and then but then
like me listening to him reminded me of
like he's into these martial artists the
way I was in the metal bands and I used
to read hit parater so those karate
magazines were like his hit parater
because he was like man I still got
those things like I'm somewhere in the
house or something like that and um
I don't know I like talking about
because I don't want that [__] to fade
because it was I mean you know 20 years
ago we did that tour in uh yeah yeah no
no this is great the um in Delirious
when that woman yelled out you just hear
shut up [__] that's that's Charlie
and that's why Eddie laughed so you knew
that right oh I didn't know that so
during Delirious that's why Eddie just
laughed and actually during the taping
it's on the special a woman yelled
something I like and an instantaneous
year shut up [__] and it was Charlie
and Eddie [__] just dropped the mic
and started walking around because he
was so protective of him
uh and and I was like that's true I
always thought he was laughing at what
the woman said because he said I didn't
bet you all didn't think I could throw
my voice he was talking about what
Charlie was saying when when Charlie
when she said it listen listen again
yeah right after she says it you hear
shut up [__] and it's Charlie
well Charlie told me stories about doing
Security on his tour and then when Eddie
came back
and was and and when in I think it was
in raw when he was talking about getting
sued and they act like he beat up the
whole bar yeah and then years later I
worked with Charlie
and was saying yeah my brother had to
let me go because I got too aggressive I
always wondered and I can't confirm that
if he was talking about
that
but he used to say I said yeah man if
we're walking down the street and
someone yo you ain't funny he goes I go
and [__] him up
he's like yeah
you're [__] talking about my brother
like that I mean it was like really like
it was hilarious dude like like that guy
I'm telling you man like Bill how old um
it was that guy I'm telling you was a
New York Legend
like if somebody ever did a mural they
got you know in all the New York Legends
you got to put him in there and his
funeral dude was incredible it was a he
got a New York he got the New York
Legend
um send-off that he deserved and it was
like it was an honor to be there like I
was just sitting there like like you
know I've been to unfortunately a lot of
funerals and that was that one was
you know
his funeral was was
like they they his friends sent him off
right I'll tell you that that's that's
amazing and great to hear Bill how old
was he when he started stand up he
started stand up after Chappelle's Show
right was he in his 40s when he started
late 40s he was like 46 or 47
well that that uh
I'm Rick James [__] thing I'm Charlie
Murphy uh that all [__] blew up and
then I think Donnell
Donnell saw it and was like dude you
should do stand up you and I will do a
thing and then they grab me
and it was like
he did two shows
two open mics and we went out on the
road and he was built as the headliner
and it was really he would do like 10
minutes this is the first couple of gigs
he would do 10 minutes he would host
and then I would go out and then Donnell
would close it
and
um
he would and Charlie was the guy who
taught me that you could write an hour
if you have to but he started in June by
August he could talk for 50 minutes it
wasn't great it was his first 50 minutes
but then he learned how
to do that
um that's incredible dude he wrote like
movies for Eddie I think he wrote uh
uh he wrote Norbit didn't he he wrote
Norbit I think he wrote Vampire in
Brooklyn I don't like
yeah and he was talking about one of
those movies I remember
he was writing that they were out in
Hawaii
and he was talking about how his family
was out there playing by the pool and
everything and he was just sitting there
[__] writing this thing that was
Norbit they wrote Norbit in Hawaii
because you know me I love Eddie so yeah
he wrote that there's [__] was hilarious
by the way well I remember we were
supposed to do the Improv no he was
supposed to do hilarities in Cleveland
and then he dropped out the last second
because he had to go fly to go write
that movie and dude like they wrote that
movie
in like two weeks
like they had that thing ready to go and
then it was like the next year I think
like they shot it or whatever and
Norbert was his idea
he was watching there's a YouTube video
there's a famous YouTube video from way
back in the day
big black woman and there's a uh
skinnier black dude he's trying to hit
her and she keeps putting her face out
and as he goes to swing she'd pull it
back and she'd hit him and he fell for
it every time she kept sticking it out
pulling it back and hitting him and then
was dragging him across the street
hitting it I went to show it to him
and then and they'd already made Norbert
I feel like when I finally showed that
to him he said yeah he goes that's
that's where I got the idea for that
movie he goes I saw that video and I was
dying laughing and I sent this to Eddie
going Eddie this is a movie you got to
be this woman
and this dude like this guy's scared
shitless and his girlfriend beats the
[__] out of him
he saw it and just was like everybody
else saw it and thought it was funny he
saw it and goes this is a movie and
showed it to Eddie and I guess Eddie was
laughing I feel like I'm really speaking
out of school here because I don't
remember how this is my remembrance of
it yeah this is a long time ago so
please don't
no that makes sense dude that makes
sense and I remember hearing that Eddie
and his brother Charlie were writing
that in Hawaii because I remember seeing
it and there were some scenes and lines
that were so because when he played the
nerdy Norbit and he just would smile
like nobody did that better than him I
mean it was the best you know guys like
that come around dude like one person
like that comes around I feel every
quarter of a century if you're lucky